how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some very
very exciting news concerning the falcon
and the winter soldier
and wolverine it seems like we're
getting closer and closer to the x-men
showing up in the marvel cinematic
universe and what
everybody wants to know is how is
wolverine the mutant who
through various movies and comics has
become one of the most popular x-men
ever going to be reintroduced on screen
after hugh jackman did such an amazing
job well it looks like his introduction
and setup is going to start and the
falcon and the winter soldier and today
we have
a little bit more evidence pointing
towards this fact as a casting call has
revealed a connection
to wolverine one that we've actually
seen before on screen but a connection
nonetheless so we'll break down this new
casting call in this video and tell you
everything
that you need to know but first big
congratulations to jonathan
mendoza for being the winner of last
week's dr doom
funko pop giveaway email me in the email
in my description and we'll get you your
funko pop
and for this week's funko pop giveaway
we're giving away a hawkeye funko pop so
all you have to do to enter subscribe
like this video and leave a comment
about the video down below so it seems
like the falcon and the winter soldier
which is going to be
one of the first projects from marvel's
face for to hit
streaming is going to cover a little bit
of the repercussions of avengers in-game
in avengers in-game we had a
five year gap between the snap and
between when the hulk brought everybody
back
but during that time a lot of stuff
happened and remember
tony told bruce not to undo anything
that happened over the last five years
now of course he said this because he
didn't want his daughter to be snapped
out of existence since she happened in
the last five years
but everything else that happened stayed
the same as well and one very particular
thing that stayed the same is that
hawkeye killed a ton
of the yakuza the yakuza are a japanese
crime organization the same ones that we
saw hawkeye take
down at the beginning of avengers end
game and what's interesting
is that the yakuza actually have a
connection to wolverine
and we'll get to that in just one second
because recently we have found out some
new casting information about the falcon
and the winter soldier
it's been reported that leon go and
kawaii
joao have been cast as yakuza members in
the falcon and the winter soldier
leon is labeled under yakuza bike rider
and kauoi
is labeled under yakuza gang now this
connects to wolverine in a couple of
different ways
one way is going back to the leaked set
photos of the falcon and the winter
soldier that we got of the biker gang
with the red demon-like face on the back
of the biker gang's jackets
it's widely believed that this figure on
the back of the jackets
is ogun and ogon is very heavily
connected to wolverine
in fact ogun is secretly the person who
created wolverine and made him into what
he is who wolverine would eventually
kill
and it looks like the yakuza may in fact
be this biker gang
and that would link the yakuza to ogun
now the yakuza are actually connected to
wolverine in another way and if this
sounds kind of familiar it's because
this is what we saw
in fox's the wolverine wolverine took on
the yakuza
in the wolverine and it was a pretty
heavy part of the story in fact a good
majority of the story featured the
yakuza
now marvel studios isn't going to retcon
anything that fox did
into the mcu so whatever happened in the
wolverine did not happen and
won't have any effect on any story of
wolverines and the mcu
but it does sound like they've found a
certain way to start to introduce
wolverine into the mcu
because this is a way to show that
wolverine or logan has been
in the marvel cinematic universe for
quite some time because remember the
falcon of the winter soldier is going to
cover
the repercussions of everything that's
happened from in-game and that includes
the damage that hawkeye did or ronan did
to the yakuza during that five-year time
period
and it seems like they may link
wolverine to the yakuza somehow perhaps
he was another person like hawkeye
trying to take them down
during this five-year gap it would
definitely be a good way to tie
wolverine into the mcu
and maybe even they can say that he was
connected to hawkeye during this time
maybe hawkeye and wolverine fought
together at some point this would
actually be a pretty cool way to
introduce wolverine because a lot of
people were wondering if
marvel is going to say that the x-men
have existed in the mcu the entire time
we just haven't heard anything of them
yet or is marvel going to have some
event
that activates the mutant x gene inside
of the mutants and now mutants are
new to the mcu but having wolverine have
fought alongside hawkeye or
ronin during this five year gap would be
an awesome way to start to kind of
bring the mutants into the marvel
cinematic universe after all we do know
that a young logan is not exactly a team
player so
if anybody would ask since wolverine was
in the mc
why didn't he go help hawkeye in
avengers in-game they could simply say
clint asked him but wolverine said no
there's a lot of awesome ways to connect
wolverine here with the yakuza and with
ogun
and i'm really excited to see the story
of how marvel is going to play this with
the introduction of
wolverine but in the meantime let me
know how you would like wolverine to be
introduced to the marvel cinematic
universe what are your thoughts on this
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe stay up to date
on all things relating to the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof